Let's pray today over day 25, entire
sanctification.
Father, we thank you for the message of 1 Thessalonians.
We thank you that you have changed us forever,
that we are definitely safe. We thank you for the assurance
that our life has been transformed by the grace of God.
We pray, Lord, that you would give us an awareness, and you have given
us an awareness
of the urgency of what is needed and what is lacking still
within us.
We want, Lord, that you would give us such an
awareness and such a hunger to know the fullness of the presence
of the Holy Spirit,
the powerful, full cleansing, and full
sanctification that you have created for us and you have provided for us in
Christ.
So we pray, Lord, that you would sanctify us through and
through, that as the God of peace, you would bring us not to a place of
war with ourself,
but that you would give us a place of peace, not only peace with you,
but peace within us as well. That we might not be
subtly
under-the-radar sabotaging by our own
selfishness,
but would you bring us to a place of peace like you are a God of
peace. And Lord, we pray for blamelessness.
We pray that you would produce this within us, this entire
sanctification, this through-and-through sanctification.
Would you bring it to us, Lord, and bring it to us in
such power that it gives us a blameless and pure life
all the way till the coming of our Lord Jesus Christ.
We pray that you would do that in Christ's name, for His sake.
Let's continue seeking the Lord together.